since he made his debut in 1988 venom
has become one of spider-man's deadliest
and most well known foes so well known
in fact that you're probably already
familiar with most of the facts about
his origin from the alien costume that
Spidey picked up in secret Wars to his
defeat by a church bell and even his
appearance in the classic maximum
carnage video game you might think you
know it all dig a little deeper though
and you might find a few facts that you
didn't know about venom venom a David
Goyer film while Tom Hardy will be
taking on the role of venom in the
characters first major solo film it's
hardly the first time someone has tried
to bring venom to the big screen for his
own movie there were plans for a
spin-off series after Eddie Brock made
his appearance as one of the villains in
2007 spider-man 3 but 10 years earlier
New Line Cinema was making a serious
effort to make venom the motion picture
happen while it never happened it
boasted a screenplay by David s Goyer
and was rumored to have Dolph Lundgren
in talks to star not a bad choice when
you consider how often artists of the
90s drew Eddie Brock to look like an
even more jacked version of Ivan Drago
Gore would eventually break through into
superhero films as the writer of 1998's
Blade and its sequels and would go on to
provide the scripts for Batman Begins
Man of Steel and dawn of Justice what
could have been truth in journalism
if big-budget superhero movies aren't
your thing you don't need to wait to see
an interesting live-action take on venom
thanks to Joe Lynch's truth and
journalism
released as a fan film in 2013 the
documentary style movie follows
disgraced photojournalist Eddie B as he
makes his way through the streets of New
York finding and occasionally
manufacturing salacious news stories
needless to say it turns out that
Eddie's hiding an even bigger secret
spoiler warning it's a weird symbiote
monster from space who eats people even
though most viewers know exactly who
Eddie B is from the first frame the big
reveal of venom at the end is well-done
intense with ryan Kwanten of True Blood
Fame doing a great job of playing Brock
as an amoral opportunist if you've never
seen it it's well worth 20 minutes of
your time and like all Marvel movies
make sure you stick around after the
credits venom vs. number 7 in the 1990s
venom was easily one of Marvel's single
most popular characters for a pretty
obvious reason he was basically Frank
Castle Plus Peter Parker with a mouth
full of teeth so long and sharp that
even Wolverine thought it was a bit much
he was so popular in fact that from 1993
to 1998 there was a new issue of venom
on the stands every single month without
missing a beat those issues just never
managed to get past number six rather
than being a single comic that ran from
number one to number 60 Venom's ongoing
adventures were broken into a staggering
17 different series that ran back to
back to back to back to Bell you get the
idea
it started in February of 93 with venom
lethal protector and ran through
separation anxiety sinner takes all
license to kill and a dozen other books
before finally wrapping up with the
appropriately named venom the finale in
January of 1998 as for why they didn't
just keep lethal protector going well
that's simple everyone knows that a
number one issue is more valuable for
collectors right and what's better than
one number one seventeen number ones
wait what do you mean that's not how
supply and demand works the thin line
between love and hate it was bad enough
when Peter Parker discovered that his
black costume was a living creature
hell-bent on controlling his body but it
got even worse when the symbiote joined
up with Eddie Brock whose hatred of
Parker only amplified the aliens
resentment after being rejected it
doesn't take a lot of analysis to see
the subtext in that relationship the
rejection the jealousy the new partner
picked up on the rebound for all intents
and purposes the symbiote is reacting
like a scorned lover
it isn't just subtext it's the whole
point of one of the greatest venom
stories of all time an amazing
spider-man number 317 Eddie Brock
challenges Peter to a one-on-one fight
to the death alone and completely
outmatched in terms of strength Peter
makes the desperate move of stripping
off his costume and seducing the venom
suit with the proportionate sexiness of
a spider
if the subtext had been difficult to see
before then the sight of Peter Parker
standing on a beach and tiny Underpants
offering up his body put an exclamation
point on the whole thing it actually
worked too but the symbiotes
relationship with Eddie turned out to be
too deep to drop all at once leaving him
passed out on the beach and his
underpants covered in a viscous ooze and
who hasn't been there after a bad
breakup
Superman smacked down while he's come
pretty close on several occasions venom
has never been able to truly defeat
spider-man once and for all he did
however beat the living heck outta
Superman so he's got that going for him
it happened in a follow up to the world
colliding DC vs. Marvel crossover to his
credit Superman manages to hold his own
but you
think that a guy who can shoot heat
lasers out of his eyes and make a sonic
boom by clapping his hands would
probably have a pretty easy time
fighting someone whose major weaknesses
are loud noises and fire and yet once
venom flies into a rage he not only goes
toe to toe with the last Son of Krypton
he also beats up Superman and spider-man
at the same time the only reason the
good guys are able to pull off the win
is the intervention of a third character
access an obscure goofball who's jointly
owned by Marvel and DC and apparently
has the deus ex machina powers of both
companies rolled into one an extra sting
in the tail if you're familiar with Mac
Gargan it's probably from his original
villainous identity the Scorpion
introduced in 1964 Guardian was a
crooked Private Eye hired by Jay jonah
Jameson to dig up dirt on everyone's
favorite web slinger when that didn't
work out triple j decided that it would
probably be a good idea to do some mad
science on him and give him a robotic
scorpion tail instead this was not in
fact a good idea in 2005 however Gargan
decided to go in a bit of a different
direction
when eddie brock found jesus he decided
to give up the symbiote and auction it
off to the highest bidder Gargan wound
up with it became the new venom and not
only did he fight spider-man in this
identity he actually replaced him by
joining up with Norman Osborn's
government-approved team of Dark
Avengers as Freddy the combination of
another villains healing powers and a
chance encounter with an old symbiote
caused a reaction that gave him his
powers back and more it turned him into
a sort of color and verted version of
venom who had the ability to cure others
of symbiote related afflictions and he
fought against crime as wait for it
anti-venom
Viva venom variety Eddie Brock and Mac
Gargan are the most well known Venom's
but they're not the only characters to
take on the identity in recent years
it's bounced around the Marvel Universe
so much that it seems like everyone's
had a shot even Groot here's a quick
rundown Flash Thompson who first
appeared back in the 60s as the high
school bully who constantly picked on
puny Parker before eventually becoming
his friend lost his legs while serving
in the Army in Iraq in 2011 his heroic
ideals in history of valor and service
made him the military's ideal candidate
for a program designed to create a new
kind of super soldier agent venom he was
bonded to the symbiote for 48 hours at a
time to keep him from losing control and
served as a member of both the Secret
Avengers and guardians of the galaxy
before losing the symbiotes back to
Eddie Brock and becoming wait for it
again
agent anti-venom if that wasn't weird
enough Thompson's time serving alongside
the Guardians also involved a mishap
that saw not just group being taken over
but rocket too and if you've ever been
startled by a raccoon by your trash cans
just imagine how bad it would be if he
had a laser gun and was also bonded with
the super-powered alien it doesn't end
there though over the years the symbiote
has briefly bonded with Deadpool
Wolverine Captain Marvel a villain named
Lee price Drax the destroyer Doctor
Octopus when he was living in Peter
Parker's body another version of
Wolverine and a kid who became venom
because he wanted girls to write
fanfiction about him no really and
that's just in the regular Marvel
continuity if you expand it out - what
if stories an alternate universe as
Venom's been well pretty much everyone
from the Punisher to Galactus the
Devourer of worlds but believe it or not
that's not the weirdest one
beware the V Rex if you go into it
looking to find out what happened to
your favorite superheroes mark Miller
and Steve McNiven old man Logan is a
pretty huge bummer focused on an older
Wolverine and a blinded Hawkeye driving
across a devastated America that's been
carved up by supervillains it devotes a
lot of pages to revealing how the heroes
of the Marvel Universe died or worse if
you like venom though buckle up as
Wolverine and Hawkeye drive spider-man's
old car through a chunk of the Midwest
that's been taken over by the dinosaurs
of the Savage Land they accidentally get
on the wrong side of a Tyrannosaurus Rex
that's bonded with the Venom symbiote to
create Earth's perfect killing machine
maybe next time drive a car without its
own arch enemy thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
you